now it's important to understand how the
application cache works together with
the http cache when we say the cache is
downloaded or appcache updates the files
in the cache those downloads are still
following the rules of http caching if
those files are already in the http
cache they may come from that cache
rather than over the network
you can still use far future caching for
example on files that you know won't
change often and when the appcache
update system needs a new copy of them
it'll pull them out of the http cache
not grab them over the network this
gives you a two-stage updating system
which can be pretty useful
however there is one file that you
should never for future cash what is it
the master html page the manifest file
or cat videos